le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous
présente lien social le Conseil général
aux côtés des Réunionnais
faire garder son enfant et très souvent
un véritable casse-tête pour une grande
partie des familles réunionnaises manque
de place ou trop élevé sont des freins
importants pour pouvoir faire garder son
enfant alors que l'on sait que c'est un
impératif pour permettre de reprendre
son travail ou de trouver une insertion
professionnelle alors existe-t-il des
solutions à ce problème on en parle
maintenant dans les liens social
pour faire garder son enfant en bas âge
jusqu'à la rentrée à l'école il n'existe
pas beaucoup de solutions il y a les
crèches souvent saturées mais il y a
aussi les assistantes maternelles cette
dernière alternative est pratique et
séduisante pour les enfants ainsi que
pour les mamans qui reprennent le
travail
une assistante maternelle est agrée par
le département et garde votre enfant
chez elle dans des conditions
réglementées et tout à fait optimale
pour le bonheur et la sécurité des
jeunes enfants
mais la mise aux normes des maisons est
assez coûteuse selon les cas et même si
le Conseil général propose des aides
pour l'aménagement parfois cela ne
suffit pas ou alors il arrive qu'elle
soit mal située par rapport aux zones de
fréquentation et donc peu pratique pour
les parents du coup des assistantes
maternelles ne peuvent pas exercer
c'est pour ces raisons que le Conseil
Général incite à la création de maison
d'assistante maternelle avec pour
objectif que les Réunionnais puissent
disposer de deux maisons d'assistante
maternelles par commune cette solution
répond aux besoins de tous les
intéressés car les parents ont des
options supplémentaires pour faire
garder leurs enfants et les assistantes
maternelles peuvent exercer dans de
bonnes conditions c'est le cas de Madame
Budel qui ne pouvait pas garder plus de
deux enfants dans sa maison car
l'aménagement pour la mise au norme
était trop coûteux chez moi je travaille
à deux j'avais une maison elle était pas
assez grande trop petite pour pouvoir
accueillir quatre enfants j'avais pas
suffisamment de moyens pour les travaux
pour pouvoir accueillir trois ou quatre
francs de plus avec mes collègues on a
décidé de travailler sur un projet donc
une MAM
donc aujourd'hui
Sophie elle est ravie d'autant plus elle
est adrée pour deux elle habitait un
appartement c'était très difficile et il
y a de qualité à pichet dans les hauts
avec sa famille c'était pas c'était pas
possible d'accueillir 4 pour les parents
c'est une bonne chose on est tous on est
trois travaillés
donc du coup les parents sont beaucoup
plus rassurés il suffit qu'il n'a une
qui tombe malade mais l'autre elle est
là donc
du coup les parents ils sont ravis ils
sont ils sont vraiment contents de
savoir qu'ils peuvent compter sur nous
toute l'année mais les enfants ça les
prépare pour l'école déjà parce que la
petite collectivité on a un petit nombre
on est à 12 entre 12 et 14 par jour donc
les enfants sont vraiment ravis et ça
permet aussi de
d'échanger plus facilement c'est
vraiment un coup de coeur pour ce métier
donc c'est un choix
de travailler avec les enfants mais de
la sorte travailler en MAM des avoir
constamment comme à la maison
c'est ce que ce que j'aime en fait c'est
aujourd'hui je je m'en réjouis de
travailler ainsi d'accueillir tous les
matins ces petits bouts et les voir
partir avec le grand avec un grand
sourire ça c'est ma joie la maison
d'assistante maternelle est une
initiative soutenue par le Conseil
Général et une alternative intéressante
pour tous les acteurs concernés le fait
de pouvoir exercer permet à une
assistante maternelle d'avoir des
revenus mais aussi de mutualiser les
coûts avec ces autres collègues et
d'échanger sur les pratiques
professionnelles
ce dispositif et d'une grande efficacité
car il apporte des solutions aux parents
et créer des emplois il est aussi
renforcé par le chèque Marmaï qui
soutient financièrement les parents en
offrant une participation à la gare de
leur enfant
il manque des places dans les crèches
donc nous agréons un maximum de
personnes pour être des assistantes
maternelles et nous permettons de payer
plus cher en le chèque Marmaï simplement
souvent les maisons des assistantes
maternelles n'ont pas les conditions que
la loi demande pour être habilité donc
aujourd'hui nous voulons créer des
maisons des assistantes maternelles pour
que ces assistantes se regroupent
qu'elles aient leur formation on les
aide financièrement à payer donc les
premiers les premiers besoins pour
mettre tout cela aux normes avoir le
cadre qu'il faut tout le matériel et
ainsi elles pourront sans difficulté
recevoir des enfants dans de très bonnes
conditions pour aider toutes les tous
les mamans papa de Lille à avoir une
place facilement nous voulons
accompagner deux MAM par commune donc
pour offrir des bonnes conditions
sécurisées d'accueil pour les parents
afin que quand il laisse les bambinos il
soit rassurés les trois premières années
de la vie d'un enfant sont très
importantes il est donc nécessaire de
pouvoir lui offrir des conditions
optimales indispensables à son
épanouissement les assistantes
maternelles apportent un confort et une
qualité de vie pour les enfants en bas
âge grâce aux maisons d'assistante
maternelle le Conseil général permet aux
parents de pouvoir travailler l'esprit
tranquille et continue de créer des
emplois d'assistante maternelle une
équation parfaite qui contribue
activement à la construction de l'avenir
de la Réunion
le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous a
présenté lien social le Conseil général
aux côtés des Réunionnais